[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas la humanidad ya
pasó por la edad del cobre y por la edad
del hierro y justo ahora mismo en este
preciso momento nos encontramos en plena
edad de los lantánidos de los que vale
estoy seguro de que la gran mayoría no
habréis oído hablar en vuestra vida de
los latín tan idos sin embargo es más
que probable que por aquí y por allá
hayáis visto alguna que otra noticia
sobre las conocidas como tierras raras
hablamos de 17 elementos químicos que
están cobrando una importancia brutal en
la economía mundial por su empleo en
multitud de dispositivos a lo que hay
que sumarle un ingrediente explosivo hoy
por hoy china es el mayor productor
mundial de tierras raras vale hasta aquí
todo en orden el problema o la cuestión
es que el gigante asiático se está
moviendo para utilizar las tierras raras
como una importante baja negociadora
dentro de su estrategia política
internacional así que las preguntas son
cómo puede exactamente aprovecharse
china de su dominio sobre el mercado
mundial de las tierras raras porque
resultan tan importantes estos elementos
minerales y alternatiba tienen los
países del bloque occidental ante los
movimientos de pekín amigos hoy en
visual político como se responderá a
esta pregunta
pero antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
el petróleo de china
quizás lo más sorprendente de las
tierras raras es que se llaman
precisamente así porque la verdad es que
algunos de estos metales son tan
abundantes como el níquel el cobre y el
zinc o el plomo incluso hasta los más
raros son 200 veces más comunes en la
naturaleza que el oro ahora bien el
problema es que los elementos que
componen las tierras raras se encuentran
en concentraciones extremadamente bajas
aunque hablemos de los yacimientos más
ricos estos 17 elementos tan valiosos
apenas se encuentran en concentraciones
del 2% como muchos
[Música]
las tierras raras son vitales para la
fabricación de productos altamente
sofisticados hablamos de todo tipo de
dispositivos electrónicos como los
monitores de pantallas planas y los
smartphones su importancia está
aumentando aún más con los esfuerzos
para reducir el consumo de combustibles
fósiles las tierras raras se utilizan en
los imanes permanentes que forman parte
por ejemplo de las baterías de los
coches eléctricos o de las turbinas de
los aerogeneradores
neodimio y samario quedaos con estos
nombres podría ser la nueva pareja de
delanteros brasileños del palmeiras pero
son sólo 2 lantánidos más eso sí estos
metales son los más buscados por la
industria del armamento sus propiedades
les hacen idóneos para los sistemas de
guiado de precisión de misiles y bombas
inteligentes así como para su empleo en
drones y aeronaves por eso a nadie le
debe extrañar que nos encontremos con
noticias como esta china se propone
limitar la exportación de tierras raras
para obstaculizar a la industria de
defensa estadounidense y es que veréis
como todos sabéis la estrella del
mercado mundial de la aviación militar
es el f-35 del fabricante estadounidense
lockheed martin pues bien cada uno de
estos aviones utiliza ni más ni menos
que 417 kilos de materiales de tierras
raras estamos hablando de que un 3 por
ciento de cada f-35 son tierras raras y
muchos os preguntaréis pero a ver cómo
demonios es posible que industrias
norteamericanas tan poderosas como la
aeronáutica o la armamentística puedan
verse afectadas por decisiones tomadas
por el mismísimo partido comunista de
china fijaos
hasta los años 80 del siglo 20 en eeuu
era el principal productor mundial de la
mayoría de estos 17 elementos químicos
la mina y la planta de procesamiento de
munt ampas en el estado de california
fue durante décadas el mayor proveedor
de tierras raras del mundo extrayendo
hasta 20 mil toneladas de mineral al día
y de hecho uno de los lantánidos
obtenidos en mont ampas el europeo fue
el que hizo posible la televisión en
color pero no aún así la explotación de
los lantánidos no era una actividad que
digamos especialmente atractiva como os
comentaba antes estos minerales se
encuentran en concentraciones muy
reducidas e incluso en los yacimientos
más ricos es decir es muy difícil y
costoso extraerlos a gran escala sin
embargo amigos los planes quinquenales
chinos apostaron fuerte por la minería
de tierras raras quizás más por una
cuestión geoestratégica que económica
una decisión que fue tomada desde las
más altas esferas y si no mirad lo que
dijo el mismísimo padre de la china
moderna tensión al petróleo en oriente
medio' y china tiene tierras raras creen
xiaoping líder de china a finales del
siglo 20
aún así tenéis que saber que para qué
china llegará a dominar el mercado
internacional de las tierras raras jugó
un papel muy importante pero que muy muy
importante su método de extracción
fijaos
[Música]
además de su baja concentración otro de
los rasgos más característicos de las
tierras raras es que son difíciles de
separar de la roca en la que se
encuentran los productos químicos
utilizados para extraer estos metales
del mineral crean escorrentías tóxicas
así que tratar como se debe
estos desechos que algunos llegan a ser
radiactivos aumenta significativamente
el coste económico de estas
explotaciones mineras
y claro no nos engañemos
tradicionalmente y la contaminación pues
no fue algo que preocupara mucho a china
lo que facilitó y mucho que este país
iniciara su producción a gran escala y a
medida que esto sucedió los precios de
los metales se desplomaron acabando con
la rentabilidad de las minas de otros
países que tuvieron que cerrar los
productores chinos aprovecharon de una
regulación ambiental prácticamente
inexistente y también de los bajos
salarios y de esta forma es como chinas
hizo con el control del mercado mundial
de las tierras raras para finales del
siglo 20 por ejemplo china había acabado
con la competencia extranjera y
acaparaba ya el 97 por ciento de la
producción mundial y fue entonces cuando
el régimen comunista quiso pasar a la
segunda fase del plan para que de qué
planes estamos hablando pues atento
[Música]
17 metales para gobernarlos a todos
amigos tras conquistar una posición más
que privilegiada
china pasó a jugar un papel en la
minería de las tierras raras similar al
que durante décadas ejerció la opep con
el petroleo pekín paso de facto a
controlar una especie de monopolio y
hace una década ya intentó utilizar las
tierras raras para sus fines políticos
en una disputa con japón
japón cuenta con destacada industria
electrónica y automovilística por ello
utiliza una quinta parte de todo el
suministro mundial de tierras raras y
por eso su economía se tambaleó cuando
china bloqueó las exportaciones de
tierras raras al país del sol naciente
en 2010 después de producirse un
incidente diplomático por la detención
de un barco pesquero chino en aguas
territoriales japonesas que beijing
reclama como propias
japón denunció a china ante la
organización mundial del comercio y las
aguas volvieron a su cauce cuando eeuu y
la unión europea apoyaron las quejas
niponas pero aún así la advertencia de
pekín quedó muy clara
todo esto sin embargo no ha evitado que
año tras año china haya reducido
progresivamente sus exportaciones de
tierras y ojo no se trata solo de que el
régimen comunista haya querido
perjudicar de forma premeditada las
economías de las potencias rivales ha
sido sobre todo una cuestión de gestión
empresarial y es que veréis en primer
lugar explotar las tierras raras es caro
así que reducir la oferta en un mercado
en el que la demanda no deja de aumentar
más y más pues ya os podéis imaginar el
resultado suministros reducidos aumento
de precios de las tierras raras pero un
momento porque lo más importante es que
china no es un mero exportador de esta
materia prima lo importante la clave es
que se ha convertido en prácticamente el
único país que ha desarrollado la
industria que refina estos metales y los
convierte en materiales listos para los
fabricantes china controla cerca del 80
por ciento de la capacidad mundial de
refinación de tierras raras y de hecho
eeuu tiene que enviar cada año a china
los minerales extraídos que contienen
estos elementos así que en el gigante
asiático se dieron cuenta del enorme
bisnes que tenían entre manos y
cambiaron rápidamente de estrategia
[Música]
desde 2015 china clausuró un montón de
minas sin licencia concedidas para
explotar tierras raras y centró sus
esfuerzos en importar estos metales de
otros países sus compras de tierras
raras en el extranjero se multiplicaron
por diez en apenas tres años para 2018
china ya se había convertido en el
principal importador del mundo de
concentrado de tierras raras por ejemplo
mi amar malasia y vietnam proporcionan
un 25 por ciento de todas las tierras
raras que procesa la industria china
y es que veréis como las nuevas
tecnologías han supuesto un boom en la
demanda de estos metales el alza en los
precios de los lantánidos ha supuesto
que las explotaciones de tierras raras
vuelvan a ser económicamente rentables
en otros países y como china no quería
perder su control del mercado lo que
hizo fue moderar su peso como productor
actualmente por ejemplo su minería
aporta un 60 por ciento de la producción
mundial de tierras raras de esta forma
su industria de refino de estos
elementos minerales compra buena parte
de esta materia prima en países
extranjeros evitando así que éstos se
conviertan en proveedores de occidentes
y amigos por este tipo de cosas es por
lo que china sigue dominando el mercado
mundial de las tierras raras aunque por
el camino haya pasado toda una guerra
comercial con eeuu eso sí por si las
cosas vuelven a ponerse feas con
washington pekín ya ha puesto en marcha
su plan vez más vale prevenir que curar
sin aumentar la producción de tierras
raras en medio de una creciente guerra
tecnológica con eeuu de esta forma el
objetivo de pekín es elevar un 30% su
producción nacional de tierras raras
algo que encaja también con las nuevas
aspiraciones tecnológicas de este
gigante que por ejemplo aspira a que
para el año 2035 todos los vehículos que
se vendan en el país sean eléctricos o
híbridos una guerra tecnológica que eeuu
tiene que enfrentar con un panorama como
éste
y no sólo eso podríamos mostrar a los
gráficos parecidos de japón o de la
unión europea y todo esto ocurre insisto
al tiempo que los 17 elementos químicos
que forman parte de las tierras raras
son cada vez más importantes para la
industria tecnológica de los países
desarrollados así que la pregunta la
gran pregunta que podemos hacernos es
hay alguna alternativa que no pase por
estar a merced de los deseos del partido
comunista de china pues atentos
[Música]
la batalla por las tierras raras
amigos a miradas no creo que haga falta
recordaros que últimamente la relación
entre pekín y washington pues no pasa
por su mejor momento tan solo tenemos
que echar un vistazo atrás y recordar la
guerra comercial o las medidas que el
gobierno norteamericano tomó sin ir más
lejos el pasado mes de septiembre del
2020 contra empresas como huawei o la
chain a semiconductor manufacturing
international corporation el mayor
fabricante de chips de china
evidentemente estas cosas no le han
hecho ninguna gracia al régimen de xi
jinping que por supuesto no se ha
quedado de brazos cruzados en diciembre
del 2020 china aprobó una nueva ley de
control de exportaciones para materiales
estratégicos por la que pekín puede
limitar arbitrariamente la exportación
de estos minerales ya sabéis la
seguridad nacional pero esperad un
momento porque eso no es todo
[Música]
lo último que está preparando china ha
hecho saltar las alarmas de medio mundo
sin a endurece las regulaciones sobre
las tierras raras controlando toda la
cadena de suministro con esta nueva ley
el régimen comunista pretende ni más ni
menos que tener bajo su control todo lo
relacionado con las tierras raras desde
la extracción hasta su exportación
pasando por todo su procesamiento
industrial para convertir el mineral en
metales refinados y estos en productos
listos para la fabricación de otros
bienes sean discos duros o misiles
tomahawk vale esto un momento en
principio es complicado pensar que china
se plantee cerrar el grifo
fundamentalmente porque de hacerlo
también perjudicaría a las propias
empresas chinas que a menudo son las que
fabrican los motores y las baterías para
las empresas estadounidenses que
utilizan imanes de tierras raras pero
claro llegado el momento si las cosas se
tuercen la pregunta que se hacen en
muchos departamentos de exteriores y
servicios de inteligencia occidentales
es qué demonios podría hacerse a pesar
de todo los chinos deciden pulsar el
botón rojo y amigos llegados a este
punto todas las miradas se vuelven hacia
japón un país que lleva una década
buscándose la vida para no tener que
depender del partido comunista chino así
que la pregunta
pregunta es qué hizo japón tras aquel
incidente diplomático del 2010 pues
básicamente actuar sobre tres vías la
primera la eficiencia
[Aplausos]
el principal objetivo de los fabricantes
japoneses ha sido reducir la cantidad de
tierras raras necesarias para conseguir
el mismo producto es decir los motores
más pequeños necesitan una cantidad
menor de neodimio así que aunque
actualmente japón fabrica más vehículos
eléctricos e híbridos que hace una
década la demanda de este metal
incluidas las aleaciones ha caído
aproximadamente un 30 por ciento desde
los niveles de 2008
la segunda vía fue buscar otros países
proveedores vietnam por ejemplo tiene
unas reservas más que notables de
tierras raras pero carecía de las
inversiones necesarias como para
explotarlas así que ahí ahí es no
aparecieron en escena las grandes
corporaciones tecnológicas japonesas
cargadas de billetes también el gobierno
que incluso ha financiado a empresas
extranjeras es el caso por ejemplo de
line es una empresa minera australiana
con una refinería de tierras raras en
malasia de este modo es como japón ha
conseguido reducir su dependencia
prácticamente total de las importaciones
chinas hasta un 58 por ciento que sigue
siendo mucho pero al menos le da un
cierto valor de oxígeno y por último
amigos ha puesto en marcha un
instrumento tan básico como efectivo y
es que veréis en tokio se preguntaban si
ya lo hacemos con el arroz o con la
gasolina por qué no hacerlo con las
tierras raras y como solemos decir
emisor político dicho y hecho
japón almacenará métele raros como parte
del esfuerzo para reducir la dependencia
de china y este este que hemos visto es
el libro de instrucciones que japón le
ha pasado a washington y al resto del
mundo sobre cómo lidiar con china para
evitar que pekín pueda castigar a la
industria tecnológica occidental
de momento eeuu ha vuelto a operar la
gran mina de mountain pass que cerró en
2002 por los requisitos ambientales cada
vez más estrictos de california y por no
poder competir con las explotaciones
chinas además los demócratas y los
republicanos se han puesto de acuerdo en
que deben impulsar una industria propia
de refinación de tierras raras para que
todo el proceso al que se someten estos
metales se haga en suelo norteamericano
en este sentido ya se ha abierto una
planta de procesamiento de tierras raras
en colorado pero claro poner en marcha
un proyecto de este tipo necesita su
tiempo y al menos hasta el 2023 esta
planta no empezará a dar sus frutos pero
lo importante es que en eeuu todos son
conscientes de que no se puede seguir
dependiendo de china y si también han
tomado buena nota del libro de
instrucciones de japón el pentã gono
otorga 30 millones de dólares a la
australiana line es para financiar
tierras raras seguro que ahora podéis
comprender por qué eurolandia ha copado
tantos tantísimos titulares en los
últimos años si se estima que por allí
hay muchos lantánidos en fin amigos
llegados a este punto la pregunta es
para ti como creéis que deben actuar los
países occidentales para asegurarse la
provisión de tierras raras hay que
colaborar con china o poner pasta para
enfrentarse a su dominio claro que abran
ventanas y los chinos tienen tierras
raras los aliados occidentales
algo incluso más importante el control
sobre la industria de los
semiconductores os recomiendo este vídeo
que han hecho nuestros amigos de bali
school sobre esta cuestión no os lo
perdáis en fin una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]